well Daka supporters celebrated outside
the Supreme Court yesterday many
so-called dreamers acknowledged there
will be more legal battles to stay in
the United States CBS News contributor
Maria Elena Salinas spoke to some of
them to get their reaction and she joins
us now Maria Elena good morning so they
went from celebration to more concern
what did you learn good morning Tony
well wild dreamers across the country
are breathing a sigh of relief knowing
that their safety their jobs and their
access to school is secure for now what
we heard the refrain that we heard over
and over again is that this fight isn't
over from the steps of the Supreme Court
to Texas in California undocumented
dreamers celebrated Thursday knowing the
daca program would continue what was it
like when you heard the decision this
morning it definitely felt surreal it's
definitely been feeling like a huge
weight off my shoulders ana Guevara was
brought to the US when she was nine this
was for and for these recent college
graduates Vata is a lifetime
I dream about going to grad school but
it's very hard when you know when you're
living in the city limbo so that's what
it means like that there is like
somewhat of a future maybe what is your
life like living in limbo when I
graduated college like I know that there
was uncertainty every month of whether
they'll get position and living in that
and surgery has definitely been a huge
overwhelming feeling everyday for me
knowing that I it's not just me but also
for my family that fear of life without
data was shared by Ricardo acha who came
to the US as a teenager I was living in
the shadows I was trying to get by I was
lying
because I guess at the time you don't
know what your status could potentially
affect your entire family akhom marched
against the Trump administration's
decision to end the program and he hopes
the court's ruling is a message to those
who are struggling before I had come out
of the shadows I didn't really have a
community I did not know other other
folks with back
for those folks that you know might not
have been eligible I think I hope they
know that we're fighting because I think
everyone deserves respect and dignity
and and I think I think that's
essentially the goal Guevara in Lopez
feel relief but like akka they know the
fight isn't over
my family and I belong here my
communities definitely belongs here and
uh we are here like we are gonna
continue our fight for a permanent
solution these dreamers told us that the
original dreamers are their parents who
came to this country in search of a
better life so they will continue to
push for a permanent solution on Capitol
Hill also yesterday Supreme Court
decision could open the door to
thousands of young undocumented
immigrants who had originally not
qualified for the program or had been
excluded from the program during the
Trump administration Gail Maria Elena
thank you it must be nice to wake up in
the morning and not have your life in
limbo dream come true for the dreamers
and that Key Biscayne background
stunning really stunning good to see you